deaths continue to spiral out of control
due to the oxygen crisis that the world
has termed the sickness
last year i had 20 kids in my class this
year i have 12.
ethan white do you know what your father
did here
meet the chronicle what if i told you
that you could save all of us
save your wife we received a message
from the future the future this is a
time machine
the people who sent the message must
have found a cure do you really believe
i'm going to save the world
you're all men you may be humanity's
only chance
to finally cure 10 9
8 7 6
5 4 3
2 1.
whoever sent the message we need to find
it
we are at the beginning of the journey
that can change
everything you have to trust me now
this isn't about finding a cure anything
something bigger at play
imagine that we are all connected by the
very fabric of the universe
[Music]
[Applause]
an invisible field that bonds us
together to you
me the stars we can't change anything
it's always going to play out this way
there is no other way
we are all connected through time about
saving the world
you